radical and repugnant Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene is
now claiming that her television turns
itself on to spy on her no she's not
crazy no she's not taking any
medications as she proudly has announced
although maybe she should be as The
Daily Beast reports green posted a
bizarre thread Sunday morning in which
she insinuated she's being spied on Via
her television uh
yeah uh her first tweet says last night
in my DC residence the television turned
on by itself and the screen showed
someone's laptop trying to connect to
the TV just for the record I'm very
happy I'm also very healthy and eat well
and exercise a lot I don't smoke and
never have I don't take any medications
I'm not vaccinated so I'm not concerned
about blood clots heart conditions
Strokes or anything else nor do I have
anything to hide I just love my country
and the people and know how much they've
been screwed over by the corrupt people
in our government and I'm not willing to
be quiet about it or willing to go along
with it now it is actually funny to see
how the supposed we don't care about our
feelings we only care about our facts
crowd immediately accepted this and said
yes the most likely scenario is indeed
that someone probably leftists or antifa
are trying to spy on green through her
television that's almost certainly what
is going on
of course at some point it might be nice
to apply sort of colloquial version of
Occam's razor is there a simpler
explanation here and of course there
almost certainly is did this not really
happen and is she lying that's a
possibility more likely than the one she
is outlining did she sit on the remote
that is a possibility is it a smart TV
with some kind of learning function that
maybe has figured out a schedule where
it believes Marjorie Taylor green wants
to be watching TV sure is it her
boyfriend Brian Glenn the guy from
Brightside broadcasting who hooked up
his laptop to the TV and uh it turned on
and went right to the last input that
was selected like any single one of
these explanations would make more sense
but then but then Marjorie Taylor green
posts an article from CBS News your
smart TV might be spying on you
now of course
what that warning means by spying is
that without your consent it's
conceivable that the microphone function
on the TV might be listening to words or
phrases that would then be used to
Target advertising towards you or that a
camera could be gathering data about
when you're sitting in front of the TV
versus when that's that's the type of
spying we're talking about we're not
talking about leftists remotely turning
on marjorie's TV
in order to be able to listen I guess to
whatever the hell it is she's talking
about politically okay so Marjorie
Taylor green insisting she's not on any
medications but maybe she should be that
would be something to look at